how's it going bros my welcome back to
turbo dismount this game got updated
there's a bunch of new levels we're
gonna check them out together today it's
gonna be fun
let's select the face all right so we
have Lord Matthew or Shia LaBeouf
I think Shia LaBeouf will get me more
views so I'll go with Shia LaBeouf there
we go
hit the fan yes I would never punch you
boys don't worry
haha it looks so ready just do it Josh
do it do it pouch your ass it's awkward
stop looking at me Jesus Christ what
force me
oh holy [ __ ] you did it oh my god
where is he going no one knows okay this
looks good that looks great
go Schuyler Shiloh go Schuyler you did
it fly on the wings of blue flash yeah
come on you can do it shout I love you
go oh oh [ __ ] what what just happened
geology first-person Shia mode here
let's do it oh my god oh my god
I'm I feel sick where am I hello
oh god ah help
oh my god Shia what the [ __ ] there you
go Shia power maximum speed
yeah don't hit the fat oh god that is
awkward
no I don't wanna ass my ass oh oh
for you yes yes Gosha wow dude
damn that was [ __ ] awesome yes
where did Shia go oh oh [ __ ] me yes
again - again
holy [ __ ]
ah that's the best thing that could ever
happen what is this what is this what is
this what is this I want to take a piss
in your face
original song just made by me right now
now actually our Kelly did it I'm sorry
all right you know what I think this is
a little too much for a Shia to handle I
think this is a job made for another man
if you know what I'm saying another man
who I dearly hold to heart I bet I've
had a bad bit about Matt all right can
we mute the [ __ ] song for a second
whew man
go go for my child go go Matthew I love
you I love you Matthew Matt down knock
out oh [ __ ] I can steer oh my god
Matthew this is a small step for Matthew
but a giant step for Matthew dance
full speed ahead goddamnit we lost
Matthew everyone I ran our ride on
Rapids I'm Matthew McConaughey that's
right I met
alright it looks like we're going back
to space preps this is this is not space
but day up and down and [ __ ] movies I'm
a movie star I'm famous yep
I'm hanging on to my career there you go
go go Matthew go Matthew Matthew he's
gonna make it no no it was so close back
there you're looking good you're looking
mighty fine there boss
robot Oh God we're serious
nailed it oh my gosh all right IRA high
score high score alright alright let's
look at this [ __ ] oh my god ha ha slower
my god yes all right all right all right
that's enough turbo dismount for today
if you bros enjoyed watching this video
please leave a like it helps me out a
lot it supports what I do and I
appreciate it thank you so much for
watching this I hope you had fun and as
always see in the next video it's always
stay awesome em sinner and I'm Xander
and Xander and Xander
Adam Sandler Adam sandy
I love you Adam Sandler I love it up